can I ask you something I did in Hawaii
that I haven't never brought this up and
I feel so ashamed about my behavior and
I want to see if you think this was I
there for this you weren't there no oh
thank God and I feel like you already
felt preemptive embarrassment yeah
and I didn't check him no you didn't
check no if you were there you would
attract me okay because this was so
embarrassing and it was like so like
let's go
I don't know my job is to bring him back
to Earth yeah yeah sometimes he just
takes off to the Moon Yeah that's the
moon but that's a good partner that's
just what about this is so gross rip it
rip it let's go all right so I'm in
Hawaii and I hear Tony Hinchcliffe is in
town are you bracing yourself what's
happening
she's getting into survival going in a
plane crash I don't think it's that bad
where you have to hold your body
let me get a check if her seat is a
flotation she's like all right so and
and I and I I want to know why I behaved
like this but so anyway right so Tony
goes come do a guest spot on my show the
second show Saturday night I'm like all
right so I show up and he has one of
those guys meet me and I'm sort of in
the club the club is packed yeah and um
so I go outside into the showroom just
to see what the audience looks like the
lights were down I think
um the show had already started right
and I'm watching and I'm looking looking
around I'm trying to get a feel because
I'm about to go up so then I go back
into the green room and a waitress
follows me back she excuse me um who are
you yeah and I go what he's like yeah um
this is for Comics only you got to go
back into the showroom right and then
one of Tony's guys goes no no no he
belongs back here right and she's like
oh okay well he looks suspicious yeah so
then because I'm a surprise guy yeah and
so when I won
also to be fair you look like a very
average Japanese guy in Hawaii
[Laughter]
right anyway right
so then what does this sound better so
when they bring me up for some reason I
mean I know why but the place goes crazy
yeah right oh boy
I'm seeing how it's getting painted
everyone everyone do the vampires
all right Bobby right the go the place
goes crazy and I just because she pissed
me off yeah I know right so I'm like you
know what yep I'm gonna hit this ball
right I hit it pop right yeah right and
I can see because she's on the right
side you know her Section yeah and I'm
on stage and I'm looking at her right
and now I can tell that she might be
scared or whatever so then I get off
stage okay and she goes do you need
anything and I just was like
and I just treated like [__] okay okay
can I tell you it's not as bad as yeah
I feel
that I feel like it was gonna be I feel
like it was going to be a malignant
tumor and it's benign yeah yeah because
I thought that we're gonna do it right
can I tell you what I thought was gonna
happen yeah yeah tell me I thought you
were gonna go on stage and after the big
pop yeah be like see I thought oh I
would never do that I don't know who
does that I don't know I don't know how
to Pat a cat
I I don't know oh no it wasn't that bad
I was just no I was because I was very
mindful about my behavior I'm like why
am I acting like this no no but the
impact wasn't as bad like I was really
bracing for something yeah no I feel my
behavior isn't cool
um it's not I wasn't cool to her it's
not bad I've done I've done a simile
I've done a similar douchey thing okay
where at the New York Comedy Festival I
was invited to do a guest set on
someone's show and I showed up and it
was sold out and the lady was like I
can't let you in and I was like oh I'm
supposed to be in there and she was like
why and copped an attitude yeah she's
like why do you have to be in there and
I was like to fix the lights so you just
wanted to play and she got oh okay and
she went in and then I went out and I
did a guest set yeah and then afterwards
she goes you didn't fix the lights and I
was like Ah that's not doshie
I like the new words
you know I kind of like instead of just
saying I was like why did I lie like I
could have just yeah yeah
that's not that's my daily behavior
that was nothing because you did it in a
cute way you were doing
yeah I got you you did the lights thing
which is fun yeah I was like I was here
to fix the lights yeah I might have
referenced it on stage yeah that's what
I think is that the douchiest thing
you've done oh no I've done I've done
real give me real douche like in the
world of Comedy just in general oh my
God uh [__] I gotta think of one I've
done a lot I hate myself so I have a
long list of stuff yeah where I've like
said stuff
I don't know I have I've never done a
you do